the opening scene features a young
Mexican man mimo Cruz who works for a
high-tech Factory as a sleep dealer here
the workers are connected to a network
via suspended cables that plug into
nodes in their arms and back this allows
them to control the virtually connected
robots that are placed on the working
site beyond the borders this advanced
technology enables people to work for
any country without being physically
present in that location the Sleep
dealers are called this because they
might collapse if they work a long time
the movie then flashes back to the past
as mimo remembers his home in Santa Ana
Del Rio ohaka Mexico we see mimo who
lives with his family in a Homestead
located in the middle of the vast
landscape at one time in the past a
river used to flow through the area but
a private water company called Del Rio
built a dam Upstream leaving the entire
area dry as a result of this the
residents of Santa Ana must pay money to
enter the facility and collect water the
facility is monitored by security
cameras armed with machine guns so
infiltration and any other way is not
possible apart from this mimo's father
wants him to participate in growing
crops on their meager field but his true
passion lies in electronics and hacking
in his spare time mimo tiners with
discarded radio parts and works on his
own creation currently he seems to be
working on building an electronic
antenna that can tap into other
Communications signals as as he
continues working on it its range
increases to far away cities allowing
him to breach any radio signals he wants
one night he intercepts a radio
frequency of Del Rio security
headquarters in San Diego California and
overhears a communication between a
drone gunship operator Rudy Ramirez and
his compatriots but this time his signal
is unexpectedly detected and they start
tracking down his location out of fear
mimo hastily disconnects the signal
before before his precise location can
be identified the following day his
father tasks him with delivering food
crops to his uncle residing in another
part of the village mimo then hitchhikes
his way to his uncle's place once there
he finds him watching news regarding Del
Rio security headquarters' mission to
neutralize an aqua terrorist intercept
via their remote controlled military
aerial vehicle on this live telecast
Rudy informs the viewers that they have
recently detected an intercepting device
which happens to be the the same antenna
made by mimo on top of his Shack
realizing that his house is the target
mimo and his uncle hurriedly run back to
the shack in order to save his father
however they are too late as the aerial
vehicle launches a rocket detonating
their entire house as mimo's father
crawls out in an injured State Rudy's
Superior confirms that he is a known
Aqua terrorist as a result he fires
another rocket at the old man resulting
in his tragic demise mimo is left
Shattered by the incident and he Mourns
the loss of his father overcome with
guilt and needing to find a way to
support the rest of his family members
he then decides to go to the city in
search of work the very next day he
packs up his belongings and takes a bus
to the city of Tiana on the way a
freelance writer L Martinez boards the
same bus and sits next to him mimo
notices that she has nodes on her wrists
for interfacing with the digital Network
when he asks where he can get some of
that she replies that he can find
someone known as cootch to connect him
she also tells him about a specific
Black Market in the city where he can
have it installed for cheaper prices
later that evening L returns home and is
greeted by her AI assistant who informs
her of her new message upon opening the
file she finds a video message from her
money lender who pressures her to repay
the money soon he also threatens to
break into her place and confiscate all
of her belongings if she fails to comply
here we learn that lse makes a living by
uploading her her memories to an online
memory trading company called true node
where viewers pay for the content
however she is not able to deliver much
of the interesting content which is the
reason why she is in debt after a while
of deliberating she decides to upload
her earlier memory of meeting mimo on
the boss meanwhile mimo goes to a shady
alley in Tijana seeking a coyot tech to
have the nodes installed turns out that
the node allows an individual to go
online and provide economic
opportunities while wandering around the
area he is approached by a random guy
who offers to install the nodes at a
very cheap price when mimo agrees he
leads him to an abandoned location in an
unexpected turn of events the guy knocks
mimo down with a rod and robs all of his
money after a while he regains his
Consciousness and heads in search of a
place to stay he eventually finds an
abandoned Shack at the edge of the city
and decides to spend the night there the
next morning L wakes up to discover that
her story of mimo has been purchased
furthermore the buyer offers her a
generous amount for another story on him
this time with much more on his
background as a result L sets out in
search of mimo and eventually finds him
sitting in an alley she asks if he found
the cootch to which he shares his
unfortunate encounter in an attempt to
know more about him L offers to help him
out and takes him to the Tiana node bar
upon arrival she prepares to install the
nodes on him revealing herself as one of
the Coots mimo wonders how she knows
about all of this to which she responds
that she learned it from her exboyfriend
as she readies for the installation she
warns him about its potential risk there
is the possibility of electricity
flowing into his body through these
nodes in case of a virus or short
circuit once his body is hooked into a
machine he can control it but there is
also a chance for the machine to exert
control over him upon getting the
equipment ready mimo takes off his shirt
causing loose to be distracted for a
moment following this mimo finally has
the nodes installed making him ready to
work as a sleep dealer the very next day
he visits a networked Factory where he
discovers numerous people engaged in
Virtual work mimo is then hired for a
construction job in San Diego and is a
lotted a spot for this virtual reality
work as soon as he connects the cables
to his nodes he finds himself on the
construction site with his robot
positioned in one of the highest
buildings for the first few moments he
freaks out due to the height but he
somehow manages to calm himself down and
begins working after a full day on the
job mimo goes to visit L at a restaurant
and expresses his gratitude for helping
him as the two start their conversation
L tries to get more information about
his background he tells her that he came
to Tiana to earn money citing his
family's financial problems he also
reveals he eats in the Central Market
every Sunday night as it reminds him of
his home but when L asks him about his
father he refuses to talk about it as
days pass by mimo dedicates himself to
hard work at the networked Factory
earning himself some good money he also
sends a portion of his earnings back to
his family making them happy and slowly
relieving them from financial burden
nevertheless there is a consequence his
energy is slowly being drained by the
nodes on the other hand L tries to
upload more memories of mimo but her
buyers complain that she is not getting
the background info they asked for it is
soon revealed that the person who is
demanding information is none other than
Rudy who has been having doubts about
the Santa Ana operation apart from all
this mimo and L start spending most of
their time together bringing them closer
and closer both of them develop feelings
for each other eventually turning their
friendship into a romantic relationship
one night the two are at L's place when
they decide to share everything about
themselves as a result they connect
their nodes allowing them to learn every
detail of one another this moment
gradually turns intimate and they end
end up making love the following day
lose who now knows everything about mimo
uploads all the details on true node
including how his father died upon going
through this information Rudy finally
has his doubts confirmed that his work
made him kill an innocent man as a
result guilt slowly begins to overwhelm
him one fine day mimo goes to visit L at
her place but discovers that she is not
home as he is about to leave a neighbor
helps him unlock the apartment door
asking him to wait inside during this
time mimo looks around the place and
stumbles upon L's computer he curiously
accesses her true note account and
discovers that she has been selling all
of his memories shortly after L arrives
home and finds him watching the uploaded
memories she attempts to explain herself
but mimo feeling betrayed storms away
from that day onward he starts spending
most of his time at the networking
Factory he works extra hours
disregarding his degrading Health L
writes an apology letter to him and also
mails him a recording of her memories
but it is still not sufficient to calm
his anger in the meantime Rudy is unable
to Bear the weight of guilt any longer
so he decides to meet mimo he takes some
days off from work and drives across the
heavily fortified us Mexican border he
locates mimo at the Central Market
having dinner he sits beside him and
confesses to being the Drone operator
responsible for killing his father
shocked mimo fleas fearing that Rudy
might be there to kill him as well
however Rudy catches him and explains
that he was only following orders at the
time now he wants to make amends by
helping him in any way possible mimo
then comes up with a plan and goes to
lose seeking her help for it later that
night he goes to the networked Factory
under the pretense of doing his night
shift after confirming that there's no
one around he opens the door for lse and
Rudy sneaking them in lse then helps
Rudy connect to a machine after which he
accesses the Del Rio security
headquarters taking command of of his
drone his superiors notice this and ask
what's going on but he tries to deflect
their curiosity they instruct him to
stop but he ignores them upon learning
that Rudy is not heaing orders the
security team dispatches other armed
drones to take his drone down despite
the setback Rudy skillfully Dodges the
attacks and makes his way to Santa Ana
after a while of heated aerial dog
fighting Rudy makes it to Del Rio water
company and blasts a hole in the dam
upon witnessing this mimo recalls how
his father used to toss Pebbles towards
the damn wall out of helpless
frustration in the aftermath of this
event mimo receives news from his home
and neighboring subsistence Farms who
are celebrating the return of ancestral
Waters even if not guaranteed
permanently on the other hand Rudy who
can no longer go back to America
relocates to one of the villages outside
Tiana and begins working there as a
water seller mimo moves on with his life
in Tijana but he gives up the node labor
job for farming fulfilling his father's
aspirations and all of that great
responsibility subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching